okay
so yeah good evening this is the
uh 21st by data cambridge meetup
uh so we are going uh
online for a few months now and
the idea for tonight is
we are going to have two talks i will
talk about them a little bit
so we we have well we started right now
and then we have the
first talk uh modeling with uh gaussian
processes by
uh vd lotion and
uh after that we are going to have a
talk by saki zak akil
what if you put your data set in a
blender
and then we are going to finish around a
quarter past
eight so
uh we are as i said before we are
parieta cambridge so this is the
uh cambridge uk local um
[Music]
meet up for for pi data
we started in november 2018 and uh
we hold our meetups uh every last
wednesday
of each month and since
i think uh four months ago we started
with the
online meetups
well of course because everything is
online now so the meetup is organized by
volunteers
so there is a federico
joris myself leandro and olleh
some of some of us are in the call
tonight you can chat to us using the
chat functionality
on zoom um
so the pi data well pi data in general
is a
uh educational program of num focus so
if you never heard about num focus
uh it is a nosferab profit
organization based in the us
they support many open source
uh projects mainly that you
if you work with data science or even if
you work with python in general
you you see a few logos in the next
slide
and you num focus supports
uh all of those projects and uh
pi data is a educational program
that is also supported by num focus they
provide us with our basically the whole
infrastructure for the meetup
the meetup website where you kind of
uh subscribe to attend tonight also
the the zoom zoom infrastructure that we
are using today
is also provided by num focus
so as i said uh they support lots of
uh famous uh open source projects that
you probably use and most of us use it
on a daily basis
like numpy like jupiter notebooks matlab
leave and well many others as you can
see
and this this is not a full list is more
projects
so if you want to get involved and help
num focus to help these projects and
also
uh to help buy data you can
uh get involved and you can uh while
participating in your local meetup
um whoever
organized it uh you can also
create your own pi data chapter on your
city if there is
not one uh you can attend by data
conferences we will talk more about that
in a minute uh there is also a
way to contribute and donate to
to num focus or to your pi data
meetup of choice or for conferences
so if you want to learn more about that
you can uh email
pydata on admin paydata.org
or also visit numfocus.org to learn more
about num focus
as you can see so there are many uh
existing chapters all over the world
and uh you can you can look for to get
involved with
uh with your local chapter
as always we are as as we are kind of
here tonight
uh meeting him as part of pi data meetup
we abide by the code of conduct not only
because it's written and it's kind of
enforced
but it because it's the right thing so
in summary as you can see the the code
of conduct says
that you should behave professionally
and of course don't treat others you
know in a way that you wouldn't like
to be treated so yeah so you can
uh have a look on pi data code of
conduct it's online just
just uh have a look for it
we also ask by data cambridge we have a
number of
sponsors so we have arm we have fetch ai
num focus and also raspberry pi that
give us a great support
um so from arm we we do have a
few uh open uh job positions
that that are advertised
you can always go to our careers website
you can ask me so i'm an armed employee
and i can also
give you uh information if you if you
want about
about the i mean about the company or
about the positions that are advertised
here
you can also talk to federico as well
so from our friends at fetch ai
they they sent us these updates
to this month so they they have an
a new autonomous supply chain demo
that they created with cambridge
university
uh also they have
more details about the autonomous agents
and
also related to healthcare and mobility
uh you can also see
uh news of course on their website uh
and i i also i was i was browsing it
early and i saw that there are some
positions advertised there and you can
have a look so that's a
fetch ai
from uh raspberry pi uh they have this
very cool
uh project that they they let us know
uh and we of course want to advertise uh
not only because raspberry pi supporters
but
mostly because it is very cool so this
is a digital making at home
in which the raspberry pi uh provides uh
live streams with uh code and and
instructions to create some projects at
home um
you can learn more uh on this uh
raspberry pi foundation dot io uh slash
home
uh i just uh wanted to highlight
this week's project is about uh retro
games
and and it's very cool really well
produced
and i recommend you for you to have a
look
there is also from non-focus and from pi
data
there is a new conference that was
announced a few weeks ago
and that's by data global that's the
first
online global conference that pi data
offers
and it's happening in november so you
see from the 11th to the
15th you can still
for a few more days send a
talk proposals to it so until the 2nd of
august
and you can find more about it on
global.pydata.org
okay so that's uh that's the final slide
so you can always uh we are always
looking for
speakers you can you can contact us uh
mainly on on twitter of peditec perito
cambridge
and also you can talk to us by email if
you like
on pyrita cambridge gmail.com
well and with that i go to the
i think i'll hand over to vidi to start
a talk uh i guess
you can just share your screen
sure i'm just gonna do that now
i guess uh you can uh introduce yourself
and just uh
start with your talk if that's okay sure
okay
uh i hope my screen is visible i'm just
going to go into
yeah okay
and you can hear me as well yes cool
okay uh thanks for inviting me i'm
super excited to be speaking at the pi
data meetup
today my name is vivi i am a phd student
uh here at the university of cambridge
and
um just i just have a short uh
quick slide um just kind of highlighting
a little bit about my research so i'm
supervised by
carl rasmussen and chris lester in the
physics department
uh my core research is around bayesian
non-parametrics and gaussian processes
so we're going to look uh closely into
what gaussian processes are in this talk
and uh if by the end of the talk i'm
able to communicate
uh just the the essence of of gps
and and how they can be used in machine
learning i think um
i would be uh super happy with that uh
before
coming to cambridge i worked as a as a
quant uh so i'm very interested in in
applications in in finance
and also in high energy physics so
uh let's just uh dive in
um so a lot of learning paradigms come
down to modeling functions
um now there are a lot of sophisticated
machine learning systems out there
many for instance you have robotics you
have
which are which are which kind of work
on mostly reinforcement learning
but there are several uh sophisticated
systems but it all really
uh comes down to function modeling in in
in a lot of systems
so if you kind of break it down and look
and look deeper and deeper you are
modeling functions so what is this
function modeling paradigm and i just
want to lay it out there
you have some x and y data and you want
to learn a mapping
f now this x and y data can be can be
anything
uh where y are usually your labels your
x can be
can be can be vectors they can be
scalars they're usually numerical data
uh but x can be high dimensional and the
idea is that we want to find this
relationship between x and y which we
call our mapping f
and uh usually in kind of standard
regression paradigms the understanding
is that
uh we we can only see x and y we don't
know the mapping f and that's basically
the object of our inference we want to
learn this mapping
f and our y is corrupted by some
gaussian noise
and this is usually this is this is done
for for convenience too to kind of
work under the assumption that you have
some y data that comes from some
mapping f uh corrupted by homoscedastic
noise
and um so let's look at the simplest
case of
regression you have some x and y data
your
data is noisy and you want to find a
function that maps
x to y so here are three examples of how
you can do that
you can either say i'm just going to fit
a line so i'm going to do linear
regression
or you can play around and say okay you
know here you can actually visualize the
data because
x is one dimensional y is
one-dimensional uh you can say no i
think that's not good maybe let's try
something a higher order polynomial how
about degree four
and then you fit it and then you know
you can say well um you know the error
is still
uh you know you still you still have
some some error so so let's try
a higher degree polynomial and then you
can see well what's happening on the
right hand side is obviously it's
overfitting
um and you kind of don't want that so
you probably say okay a degree four
polynomial but how exactly would you do
this process when you can't visualize
your data and that's usually the
paradigm you're in you can't really see
your
x data because your x is high
dimensional
and so this setup of finding a mapping
f for some x and y data that you have is
called regression it is
the uh kind of main workhorse of of of
any machine learning system you are
probably doing regression somewhere deep
down in your
sophisticated machine learning system
and so my phd research is all about
looking at regression closely
using gaussian processes so as i said
if your x is high dimensional you really
can't visualize your data
and then model selection becomes a super
hard problem
uh because you can't really um you can
you can visualize your data so
you have to work uh by looking at other
metrics and usually this is model
selection in regression
is it's it's a hard problem and there's
a lot of research that
uh tries to target it so uh moving
on uh i'm just gonna try and summarize
conventional learning before we kind of
dive into like bayesian machine learning
and i usually like to introduce bayesian
machine learning by contrasting it with
conventional learning
so in the conventional learning setup
you have some x and y data
and then you pick a parametric model for
instance
you know you say you want to fit a line
so here uh you
you just pick a linear model and then
you train the model by
typically minimizing some notion of a
loss function so you learn your
parameters your beta not beta1 and
the kind of noise variance and then you
make predictions for any
unseen x-star so any test data by just
plugging in that x-star with your fitted
parameters into your parametric model so
this is standard regression
and this is conventional machine
learning you learn some parameters by
optimizing a loss function
and then you plug in um your your your
unseen data as and when you get it
into your parametric model using the
fitted parameters
so and here you're learning the
parameters so a lot of i mean
and this is this is conventional machine
learning so i mean when i started i was
like oh okay
this is regression i mean the statistics
world this is regression but this is
also conventional machine learning
uh it's just a question of semantics
really
so um how then i mean what is what is
different about kind of the bayesian
version of machine learning so i kind of
i'm going to start by just summarizing
this graph on the left hand side we have
the conventional learning framework we
learned some point estimates for our
beta parameters which are parameters of
our linear model so our parameters are
fixed unknown quantities and on the
right hand side
you have the bayesian incarnation of
this regression where you are learning
not just a point estimate for your
parameters but an entire distribution
so that means you have now a
distribution
of lines compatible with your data so
this is basically doing bayesian linear
regression
on the right hand side and conventional
linear regression on the left hand side
so how then do we go about learning this
distribution
over our parameters that give us a
distribution of prediction lines
compatible with our data
this is just um bayesian machine
learning all of the salient aspects of
it summarized
on one slide so you have again you start
with some data
x and y supervised learning framework
you have some parametric model
say you want you know you know you just
want to fit a line you start by
specifying two quintessential
ingredients that you need for bayesian
machine learning
one is the data likelihood and the other
is the prior
so the data likelihood summarizes what
is the likelihood of
seeing this particular data set um under
under your particular chosen parametric
model so the data likelihood summarizes
that
and in basic linear regression this data
likelihood is chosen to be
is chosen to be just a normal
distribution or a gaussian distribution
where the mean is just your chosen
parametric model which is the linear
model here
and some noise variance because you have
noise in the data
and then you go about by specifying a
prior distribution for each of your
theta
parameters um and you know just i'm just
giving you an example here
i'm just saying i just want standard
normal parameters over my over
all of my theta i so your each eye i
mean for all
so theta i is basically beta or not uh
theta one theta two theta three and um
so they correspond to the parameters of
my linear model and the inference step
is then just learning a posterior
distribution over
my parameter space which is theta and
that just falls out of bayes rule
so usually it's not easy to just compute
the posterior you can't uh
this uh you can't really compute this
posterior distribution in closed form in
most cases but we
look at that and how that works in gps
and then finally once you have your
posterior distribution over your
parameters
you your prediction step is just
essentially deriving a predictive
posterior distribution which is done in
step four so
this is that this is the essence of
bayesian machine learning on
just one slide you have to specify two
ingredients your data likelihood and
your prior
you learn your posterior and then you
derive a predictive posterior
distribution so you're working with
distributions no point estimates anymore
so moving on gaussian processes
implement bayesian learning so they are
a bayesian machine learning model and
they're also
a non-parametric and in a lot of the
cases they give you
state-of-the-art performance in
regression and
the two kind of key principles are that
they're probabilistic so that's great
you have a sense of uncertainty around
your predictions
now this is super useful because a lot
of the downstream tasks
might actually use this uh prediction
uncertainty that you get for free when
you use a gaussian process
model and they also don't have standard
parameters so you don't need to say okay
do i want
a cubic spline do i want to fit a
polynomial of a certain degree do i want
to fit
or do i want to fit a quadratic linear
you know you don't need to take these
decisions and it and
and we'll come we'll see exactly why
that is the case
so gaussian processes work by specifying
a prior distribution
directly in the space of functions and
uh this is like the key the key thing
about gaussian processes and you're
going to spend the rest of the talk
really understanding this notion of what
is meant
by a prior distribution in the space of
functions i mean
i can think of a distribution over a
number or vector
things like that but a distribution of
functions if you haven't encountered it
before
this is um a bit of uh this is this is
this is the key part and can be
challenging at first to kind of wrestle
with the with the idea
but i think it's it's it's it's super
elegant and super easy
to follow once you kind of catch the
idea so
the main thing is to uh clarify this
interpretation of functions in gaussian
process so when we think of a function
in mathematical sense we say
okay um you know a parametric function
so you immediately think of a parametric
form okay is it going to be linear is it
going to be quadratic is it going to be
you know a cubic is going to be
exponential but in the gp world
there's a fundamental shift in thinking
about functions we completely abandon
the parametric form viewpoint so we
think of a continuous function
f on the real domain uh
and uh we get we just think of this f as
a
function as as an infinitely long vector
so this is
evaluated at some index set um
x and so you just just think of a
function as just this this really long
vector
now the problem with this obviously is
that we can't really represent
infinitely long vectors on a finite
memory computer
that is true but just bear with me for
one second
so gaussian processes are probability
distributions over random functions so
when you
take a sample from a gaussian process
you actually get a function
and this idea of thinking of a function
as an infinitely long vector is as
it will actually prove very useful so
exactly like how in a gaussian
distribution you have a mean and a
covariance matrix in a gaussian process
you have a mean function and a
covariance function
so um what is then a gp
like what is i mean we're still kind of
going to get we still have to get the
crux of what what exactly it is um
so i i usually like to uh think of gps
in relation to gaussian distributions
so on the left hand side you have a one
dimensional gaussian distribution
samples from that are just numbers right
scalar values
on the right hand side you have a
bivariate gaussian distribution of a
gaussian pump
and which has a mean vector and a
covariance matrix which is two by two
so samples from your bivariate gaussian
bond are just vectors of size 2.
in the same way a sample from a
k-dimensional gaussian distribution is a
vector of size k
so a gp is nothing but the infinite
dimensional analog
of a gaussian distribution so then a
sample from it is a vector of infinite
length i mean just
carrying forward the same argument that
is true however
for most i mean in in the real world
at any given point we only need to
represent our function
f x at a finite index set so
we have an index set to say of 500
points for example or a thousand points
i mean here i've given my example with
500 points
and we have a function vector which has
like 500 coordinates on it so now we're
representing
this really long function vector and
that's our function
so the mathematical crux is then that
this function
is just a draw from an n-dimensional
multivariate gaussian
of dimension the size of the index set
so if your index set is size 500 a
sample from a gaussian process
is a function vector of size 500 which
you can just represent on a graph
of plotting alongside your x values
which comes from a multivariate gaussian
with a mean vector
of size 500 because your index set has
dimension 500
and a covariance matrix which is
computed by applying the covariance
function that the user chooses
at all pairs of the x data points or
your index set
so essentially we're kind of now is this
like a trick where we think of
an infinitely long uh kind of vector
which is our function which has support
over the real line
but what we actually represent and what
we compute with is actually just a
function
over a finite index set and you can and
this actually
arises from the marginalization property
of gaussians
so we are marginalizing away everything
that's not in our index set
right so infinitely long and we just
take our 500
subset of that infinitely long vector
and we're just marginalizing away
everything
outside of this index set and in
gaussians it's super easy to do
marginalization you just ignore the
dimensions that you don't want so
mathematically speaking that's what's
actually happening here so when you tell
a computer to give me a sample from a gp
with the mean and a covariance function
it'll ask you for an index set and then
it'll just give you a sample from a
multivariate gaussian
so here are examples of gaussian of
essentially samples from different
gaussian process priors with different
kernel functions or covariance functions
and they all have zero mean so mean
function is just constant
zero so you can see all of the function
draws actually
kind of are going up and down around
that zero line
so um each each line uh
is is essentially a function draw from a
gaussian process with a particular
mean function in this case zero and a
kernel and the name of the kernel is
is on top of these subplots here so the
main thing
uh that i'm trying to communicate here
is that you can encode different types
of inductive biases when you work with
gaussian processes
you can say i want to do inference i
want to cast a distribution in a space
of really smooth functions and you go
for the square
exponential kernel or you can say i want
to work with
functions that have periodicity because
i know my data has periodicity so then
you could choose the periodic kernel
or you could say you want more rougher
functions like you know
in kind of the financial world you you
need you you know
the functions are are never really
smooth so you could uh go for something
like the matern kernel
so you can encode different types of
inductive biases like smoothness
periodicity
and sort of roughness etc
by selecting your kernel function so in
reality these are all just draws from a
multivariate gaussian where the
covariance matrix has been constructed
by applying the covariance function
to points on your index set and as i
said the kernel function is really the
heart of a gaussian process it kind of
tells you
what kind of inductive biases you want
to encode so uh
your distribution of functions how do
they look so the kernel function really
uh makes that uh choice for you so there
are
several covariance functions kernel
functions i mean some text called
covariance function i like to call it
kernel function
sometimes i switch between they mean the
same thing
and the idea is that each kernel depends
on some hyper parameters theta
so here is a list of your most popular
kind of kernel functions and uh usually
people uh just pick the squared
exponential because
uh you want to fit a smooth file it's a
good universal choice if you don't
really know uh you know what kind of
inductive bias you want in chords
so a lot of a lot of the papers just
work with the square exponential
uh kernel function so okay
that's cool but then how exactly do we
fit functions uh you know to noisy data
with gaussian processes so this is nice
you you can you can
uh sort of we know how a prior over
function space works and we know how to
draw samples from it but we really need
to do inference now we need to we
learn a function uh given some noisy
data so that's exactly what gaussian
process
regression is about so we have the same
setup we have some noisy data
at some input locations x and we believe
that
uh you know it's corrupted by some
gaussian noise and then it's just
turning the crank of bayesian machine
learning we specify a data likelihood
and we specify now
prior over functions so now instead of a
prior over parameters
uh we have a prior of a function so a
function is the parameters
and this function comes from a gaussian
process that's our prior
with some kernel function that the user
selects and this is an example of
gaussian process regression in action
so on the left hand side i'm just
showing you random draws from a gaussian
process
uh where i've kind of selected the
square exponential uh covariance
function
at my index set i think which is like
500 points so then you get this really
smooth
um structure and then on the right hand
side you have the posterior over
functions and i'm going to tell you
mathematically how this posterior is
derived
so once you observe some data given by
the black
crosses here you are essentially saying
you want you're essentially doing
inference and this act of going from the
prior on the left hand side to the
posterior
is the learning step in a gaussian
process so what happens is then in
in terms of the function space you are
discarding all of your functions that do
not
pass through your data and you're just
you're just left behind with functions
that
are compatible with your x data point so
here i'm assuming that
uh the x crosses are noiseless that's
why all the functions
that are in uh that are draws from the
posterior pass exactly through the data
points
now a cool property of this posterior is
that if you look at the regions where
you don't really have any data
like on the extreme left on the extreme
right in the posterior the functions
vary a lot because we don't really know
where uh what the truth is out there so
then you uncertainty blows out on the
left-hand side on the right-hand side
and this is a really cool property that
you have a sense
a strong sense of prediction uncertainty
when you do inference with gaussian
processes
but it's still not clear how exactly do
we go from this prior over function
space to this posterior of a function
space and that actually
is quite straightforward um so left hand
side
same picture you have your prior over
your function space
with some kernel function and some hyper
parameters theta
and on the right hand side you have your
posterior that is just derived by
applying
the bayes rule to it and in the case of
gaussian processes you can exactly
compute
this posterior over your functions and
that's just that what i've written up
there
is just essentially bayes rule for
functions
in function space um in in in kind of
the gaussian process context
so the bayes rule essentially allows you
to flip
p a y given f and now you can find the
posterior
distribution or f given y where y is
your black
cross data points here uh so it's really
as simple as that
but then what about these hyper
parameters and your kernel function you
know each kernel function i said comes
inbuilt with some hyperparameters and
they need to be tuned
so essentially the tuning of the hyper
parameters happens by
by maximizing the evidence which comes
in the denominator
uh p of y given theta so this is the
objective that's used
to learn your hyper parameters in a
gaussian process and the reason that
this is a really good objective because
it tells you the probability of the data
condition on just
those hyper parameters and you maximize
this so here i've just written it down
explicitly
it's usually easier to work with the log
of the marginal likelihood or the
evidence
rather than the evidence directly so the
tuning of the hyper parameters then just
happens
by maximizing the log of the marginal
likelihood
essentially that's learning in a gp
and then uh so here i'm just kind of
showing
uh what happens when the learning
happens so here
the blue line given by the pink band
is the solution that you end up getting
when you tune your parameters
like uh the the green line given by the
green prediction intervals is
is is overfitting clearly and the
peach or the orange band the white one
is
under fitting so the lens scale is too
long there
and so when you tune your hyper
parameters you end up getting a solution
that is just about right which is the
blue
uh mean there along with the pink band
which is actually blue but then when you
plot it on the orange it
kind of becomes pink but essentially
there's this
uh so so it's a good objective it it
kind of gives you functions
with just the right level of complexity
because of this inbuilt trade-off
between model fit and complexity so
that's why this is a good objective
um so what about then predictions
in a gaussian process we want to infer
some latent function values
f star for some unseen data points x
star so we want the predictive posterior
distribution
and it turns out that in a gaussian
process you can exactly compute your
predicted posterior distribution and
they also turn out to be
gaussian so um this can best be
understood
uh first by understanding a gaussian
identity of kind of how do you derive
the conditional from joint
so if you have a joint gaussian so here
i'm just giving you
an example of a two-dimensional gaussian
on the left-hand side so if you if you
have this joint distribution you can
just easily compute the conditional this
is a mathematical fact
or a statistical fact and this is just a
gaussian identity if you have the joint
of x1 and x2
you can compute x1 given x2 or x2 given
x1
and you can do this if your your joint
was you know had several dimensions it
doesn't matter you can always go from
joint to conditional
when you have gaussians and and uh this
is just
basically uh you know a statistical
identity that holds and that is used in
computing the predictive posterior
so then the idea is you specify your
joint distribution over all of your
latent function values
f and your f star which you don't really
know you want to infer
f star and you you you can just write
down the gaussian distribution for that
because you have your kernel function
you
do you derive your you just have you can
then compute your kernel matrix you can
you have all these quantities
and then in the same vein you can also
write down the joint distribution of y
comma f star where the only difference
is that now you have to add the noise
variance coming uh
that gets added to your covariance
matrix here and
and because your y is noisy your f is
latent and without the noise
so you can just write down the drawing
distribution in the gp and then once you
can write down the joint you can always
derive your conditional distribution so
it's just going from joint to
conditional applying the gaussian
identity and you can write down your
final predictive posterior gaussian
distribution with your
new mean and your covariance here and
this is what is depicted on this plot
here
on the right hand side i'm just showing
you samples
from this predictive posterior
distribution all now
learned and now so all compatible with
your
data points given by the black crosses
here and on the left hand side
this um gray band is just essentially
taking the diagonal of your learned
covariance
your your predicted covariance matrix
and it's just plotting two sigma
and so the the true function is given by
the blue line here and the
learnt function the mean of the
predictive posterior is depicted by the
red line
and so the cool thing again you get
these prediction uh intervals for free
when you use a gaussian process this is
not something you get when you try to do
regression with deep learning or with
neural nets
uh it's it's very hard to get good
prediction intervals in kind of doing
patient
learning with with deep neural nets is
super hard so and in gps you just get it
for free and everything is closed form
so then this is a code snippet
that i i wrote up i mean this is um
basically just doing
gaussian processes in ski-kit learn you
create some training data you create
some test data points
and uh the way then the starting point
of
starting to use your gp is specifying
your kernel function you can add several
kernel functions so kernels are closed
under those operations so what i'm doing
here is i'm
declaring some custom kernel function
here which is
i'm saying i want a my turn kernel i
want to add a constant component and
then i want to add white noise
and then i initialize my kind of gp
regressor
there should be a gp is equal to here
and then i just say gp fit
and i just give it my x and y data it's
as simple as that it's key kit learn
um and then you kind of do your
predictions by predicting at your unseen
x data point so literally without the
comments and white and
these spaces here it's 10 lines less
than 10 lines of python code to fit a
gaussian process
and do regression when you're doing
regression in in
low dimensions i would never use
anything but a gaussian process
if if i can select a good kernel and
even then i think a square exponential
universal
kernel choice works pretty well for most
data sets
um so there these are kind of other
probabilistic programming frameworks all
in python
that also offer gaussian process
gaussian processes i mean of course the
syntax is a little bit different
but you can you can fit gps in maybe
even lesser lines than this in pyro in
tensorflow
in pi mc3 and edward so all a super
um super cool uh probabilistic
programming libraries
and i mainly use a lot of pyro and i
also use some pi mc3
so this is just an example of how easy
it can be to actually
use gps to to to fit functions are
really flexible
functions uh without having to select a
parametric model
so um a really really cool idea and if
you haven't used gps before
i would really recommend that you uh try
it out because it's uh it's super
powerful
um and super easy in python so
um this is my last slide um where can
you use gps
i mean a lot of people like ask me this
and i say i do like you know research
and she said okay you know fine but you
know where
what exactly you can literally use gps
in any framework where you have x and y
data and in fact you can also
use gps and unsupervised learning where
you just have
an x data and you don't have y data and
so there's a lot of good research coming
out where gps are used for unsupervised
learning
density estimation tasks the main
challenge is selecting a good kernel
so that's what my research is about how
do you select or construct a good kernel
that generalizes well um and so my phd
research is all about that
uh gps are used in several
industries uh here are just some
examples i mean they're used a lot in
finance they're used
in kind of i mean so it kind of uh the
idea of gps comes from uh
krigging which was used for spatial
modeling it continues to be used in
mining
um even even like right now uh um as of
like in these current times and also
gps are used uh for time series
forecasting modeling you can you can use
them for even unsupervised tasks related
to time series so literally
uh they could be used practically any
setup where you have x and y data
they're also used a lot in science in
astronomy high energy particle physics
uh practically like i said any
statistical modeling task where you have
a reasonable number of dimensions and
not a reasonable number of training data
so they scale poorly
in with a lot of training data you can't
use a gp if you have
uh say more than a few thousand data
points but then
there are a lot of uh you you can use
other incarnations of gaussian processes
like sparse gaussian processes which
work on using a subset so if you have a
million data points you can still use
the gp but you have to work a little bit
on kind of massaging your your data set
uh down to a reasonable size
but uh basically um that's it uh from me
so this is uh this is my last slide i'm
gonna leave it
at this uh thank you so much for
listening and i'll be happy
now to take any questions
yes thank you thank you vidi that was
really really interesting
um i uh well i think i would
i will have a start with questions uh
i've got one
and in the meantime uh people the
rest of the audience if you want to ask
your questions
please use the q a
functionality so i i will go with this
first and this will give you time to
write yours so my first question is uh
is about
training using your gaussian processes
is there any difference kind of uh in
the training phase
by the nature of all that you explain
that makes it different from
training kind of a neural network or
training any other model
can you take advantage of kind of
parallel training and and
hardware features and things with uh
gaussian processes as well yeah yeah
absolutely so
uh the way that training works in gps is
by
we just go yeah so so this l quantity
here is the is is basically the log
evidence
and that is the objective in training
gps now usually in any bayesian machine
learning model you can't compute the log
marginal likelihood or the log evidence
in closed form
uh but in gps you can compute it in
closed form
so this is like one a major uh
differentiator
like i don't think you you you can't
compute uh the the log of the marginal
likelihood
say in in in a neural net
where you put a prior over the weights
of a neural net you you can compute it
in closed form
so in that sense gps are special where
you can compute this so so all of the
math the the probability calculus is
actually all tractable
you can just write down the the log
evidence and that and you feed that
objective to your optimize and then just
run
bfgs or atom uh on it so
um there's also i think that you there
is there is some work
on training and you can you can sure
leverage gpus for for for training gp so
i think like tensorflow probability
offers you uh the ability to uh leverage
gpus for for training gps
uh so you can certainly do that and and
to get a huge
uh kind of computational performance
boost and in terms of
distributed training of gps i have seen
some work
where you can actually train gps in a
distributed way
so i think um a simple a simple idea is
where you can actually chalk up your
your your your data sets and you can
kind of feed them to
say different uh different cores and you
can kind of fit gps there and then kind
of combine them so there's a lot of
advanced
uh sort of uh machine learning systems
that
use gps but they kind of use these
incarnations of gps
uh internally uh in in in kind of
different ways
so and then to kind of build up this
large model so yeah i certainly have
seen uh some work on kind of using gps
and distributed computing framework
okay yeah well thank you so
um we got a few questions on the chat
i will start them uh in order um so the
first one is
uh what happens when there is too much
data points
uh that the gp does the gp needs to be
modified
yeah exactly so uh if you look at the
um great question uh what is one of the
weaknesses of gps is that you can't just
apply a gp to a really super high data
set mainly because you need to compute
this uh inverse of your kernel matrix
and a matrix inversion operation is o of
n
cubed so uh you can't really invert a
matrix
um kind of a bigger than a few thousand
data points on
on on any average computer so that's the
main reason because you have this matrix
inverse operation there
you can't uh just throw a gp on a really
a huge data set i would say anything
more than three four thousand
is a problem so then you need to use uh
sparse gaussian processes which actually
work by selecting
a subset of data points from your kind
of n
um data points so you select m data
points and
uh and kind of do inference with those
uh
with that smaller informative subsets so
there's a lot of
interesting research on sparse gaussian
processes because most
uh implementations of gps in production
in industry use sparse gaussian
processes because the data sets are
larger than a few thousand data points
so yes you can absolutely do it but
you'll have to modify
the gp okay
next one is
may i ask how gp can be used in
unsupervised learning settings
yeah so you can use gaussian processes
for uh things like a latent variable
modeling
so one of the projects that i'm working
on right now is is using the gaussian
process latent variable models of a
dimensionality reduction
so assume that you have some data which
is in high dimensions
and say you have 500 data points each
data point is 10 dimensional
you can use a gaussian process to learn
a mapping from x to y where your x is
invisible it's latent
but your x is also low dimensional and
so these models are called gaussian
process latent variable model so you can
learn for your high dimensional data
point
a corresponding latent point in a low
dimensional
space and it kind of it's it's a similar
idea to pca but using now
the non-linearity afforded to you by the
kernel function embedded in a gp
to learn that flexible latent
representation so yeah if you look up
gaussian process latent variable models
there's a lot of stuff on that on how
gps can be used on supervised learning
okay thank you so next one is uh
you mentioned scaling with training data
how do gp scale with
number uh of input output dimensions
does kernel
does the kernel choice impact on uh how
lgps scale
so i mean the kernel so yes gp scale
n cube in in in the uh number of
training data
and you also have a multi-output gps
where your uh y data is high dimensional
so usually your inputs are high
dimensional and your y is scalar but you
also have
multi-output gps which is an advanced
incarnation of gps
where you have high dimensional x and
also high dimensional
y so in that case i think a knife it
would reliably
just scale n cube d cube where d is the
dimension n
is the number of data points so it
scales poorly so it's basically cubic
scaling
and so you can't afford that uh when you
uh need to
invert a matrix and which is something
you can't get away from when you're
fitting gps you need to invert these
kernel matrices and you can't afford
uh to to to do that uh right with large
data sets so the kernel choice i mean
not so much in terms of scaling but of
course you need to compute the kernel
matrix so if your kernel has several
different it has this long complex
analytical form that's obviously going
to add some cost but i would say the
main bottleneck is the number of data
points
the number of training data points and
the gps in their standard incarnation
scale
poorly they scale an n-cube
okay um thanks for that the next one
the second last one will be can you use
gp to choose your kernel
in theory since uh i presume you'd need
a super computer
to choose your kernel okay so i'm super
interested in this area of kernel
learning where uh you're kind of doing
meta learning right so you're saying
that oh yeah you want to use a gp but
you want to have
a pre-step where you are using a gp to
learn
a kernel so actually there is a a recent
paper in europe's that that came out
from andrew wilson's group and nyu
where they uh kind of think about a
distribution over kernels
so you can actually re-parametrize a
kernel
uh in in in terms of a spectral density
and then you can
use a gp prior on that spectral density
and then so that gives you a
distribution over kernels and then do
inference it's a super hard model to
train it's it's it's really
i mean i haven't played around with it
i've just read the paper but effectively
yeah so there
is uh current research where people are
kind of using
gps in a meta learning type of way but
they're taking a step behind saying okay
fine
before i select my kernel let me not
just make a hard choice
let me learn my kernel so yeah there's
certainly a
research very new research in that area
right now
okay thanks and the last one is
which regression techniques compete with
gps in learning
time and prediction accuracy how are gps
being improved to overcome their
limitations so
um great i mean so i mean in terms of
like
maybe maybe i'm biased because i've been
working with gps for the better part of
last two or three years but
uh i think that if you have low
dimensional
uh data and a reasonable number of data
points it is
really hard to beat the performance of a
gp so
uh in a lot of papers you'd see that uh
gps are used as like the
the benchmark and uh they kind of show
you
uh when they have a proposing a new
model they they always compare to the gp
benchmark so it's it's a good
it's it's a good baseline but then
usually these models computationally
they cost a lot more but then they they
might give you a little bit of a
accuracy performance so i would say if
your modeling task
is is in under 20 dimensions under a few
thousand data points
just use a gp and focus all of your
effort on coming up with a good kernel
so you can combine kernels to encode
different types of structure in your
function space
and once and i think all of the research
effort uh when
gps are used in industries how do we
select this kernel because this kernel
choice is super important
um there are a lot of papers where gps
have been compared with neural
networks also they are mathematically
related so a multi-layer
perceptron a one-layer hidden neural net
uh with where the hidden layer going to
infinity is equivalent to a gp so
there's like
this is an interesting kind of fact that
i learned uh you know a year or two ago
so this was proved in uh radford neil's
thesis in
95 so so gps and neural nets are related
and a lot of the times they are compared
uh but then i don't think the prediction
intervals that you get from a bayesian
neural net
are as good as that of a gaussian
process so in terms of
the quality of the prediction
uncertainty so if you're in a
in a framework where the prediction
uncertainty is super important and you
need robust uncertainty
you should use a gp so i think they work
better than neural nets but then if you
have really large scale data working
with like images or something like that
maybe a convolutional neural net
so it really depends on your application
okay thank you very much there well that
was many questions
uh thanks for your talk uh
we are uh
there was one more question in the chat
not the q a
yeah okay uh yeah i was going i was
going to say that uh as we move to the
to the next talk uh maybe uh
she can reply to that question on the
show the chat okay
sure sure yeah so you got one more big
question on the chat
cool so uh yes
so now
we are going to
go to the next talk so that uh
suck
hello i think yeah i think well if you
are ready you can just uh
introduce yourself and yeah absolutely
i'm ready
let me let me present my screen here and
we can get started okay uh can you see
that can you hear me
yes okay awesome uh one thing i actually
also want to check
i'm wondering if i can so i can see
the list of participants on my screen uh
there's a tool where you can like raise
your hand i'm wondering can we test out
like anybody who's able to do the raise
your hand thing can you test it out now
so i can see
oh cool okay that's awesome all right
okay oh that's that's really cool uh so
yeah then i can kind of level check with
people like uh about certain topics
that's excellent so be
prepared to use that uh cool let's get
started so yeah
my name is zach akeel i'm a machine
learning engineer and developer advocate
at google
and i'm giving a talk today about what
happens if you put your data set in a
blender
and a bit of background on me so i i
like kind of building random things with
machine learning
i've got a background in software
engineering and like kind of full stack
like building kind of
weird stuff and uh also in data science
so i run a data science meetup
based in london called central london
data science where i kind of teach data
science and machine learning to anybody
who wants to learn it
and yeah these are some examples of
projects that i'd built in the past
this one on the left here is a sort of
real-time
neural network visualizer so it's
actually
taking the neural network model that you
can learn in a scikit-learn
and in real time using a raspberry pi
and some leds it's actually displaying
the values of the weights
and kind of theme with my inventions
they are
pretty much useless in terms of
practicality they're just mostly kind of
cool things to look at so that's
kind of the example of things i like to
build uh another example
is this one here i'm gonna show this is
a
robot that i built uh built this last
year
or a year or two ago for um sort of new
year's resolutions
and this is an example of like using uh
machine learning
image classification again kind of using
raspberry pi is like i like building
physical
sort of hardware based demos because
they're kind of like the more more fun
ones
and yeah this is using a tool like
google has where you can just like drag
and drop images in
i google searched um junk food and
healthy food and trained a classifier
and then
the raspberry pi is just responsible for
taking a photo saying
it to the api getting back the
prediction of moving the server
uh so yeah those are examples of
projects so you can follow me on twitter
if you're interested in
seeing more of those projects uh i want
to talk about uh
today as an actual tool that i've sort
of invested a lot of time into recently
given the circumstances um with these
kind of physical demos like they have
the most impact like in person
and unfortunately we can't do more
in-person demos so i've now kind of
pivoted
to more virtual demos and a tool
that i've chosen to learn uh over
lockdown has been a tool called blender
now raise your hand if you're familiar
with blender
okay oh we've got okay a good chunk a
good chunk of people are familiar with
blender now if you're not familiar with
blender
blender is an incredibly great just
beautiful bit of sulfur
and it's an open source kind of 3d
animation tool
it's been around for years like it's
like i was
talking to someone and then yeah it's
like been around for days like 10 years
ago like it's a very old bit of software
but it's in constant development
so it's like a beautiful example of like
the greatness of like open source
software
and uh it's now being used for like
actual
filmmaking because the quality of it has
just been getting better and better over
the years
and over lockdown i invested time in
fact i i can
show you this so i did this course from
udemy that teaches like how to use
blender because if anyone's ever used it
they are probably aware like the
interface is pretty intimidating
and in fact let's let's let's move into
it now let me show an example so here is
here is blender here's the interface
this is like when you start a new
project
just to show you i go new project uh
don't say
this is like the default project you get
a cube to work with
and yeah this is this is a it's like the
pinnacle of 3d animation so you can
move around the cube and that's that's
it
that's all you need to know about
blender you can move around cubes but
what's interesting is one of the less
sort of uh
spoken about features of blender is it's
got a really really cool
python interface and this is something
that like blew my mind like i did the
whole course i didn't mention anything
about this and then i
i found out that it has this interface
played with it and it just like changed
my world so
let me show you the python interface so
i can
i can create a new tab and i can do this
thing here
which is i can go create an info tab now
this is cool
uh so this will tell me and i've never
seen this in any other software except
for this one so this this blew my mind
as well
so let me i can delete this cube and
then i'll recreate it so i'll go like
add
mesh cube okay so it's fine we've got
the same cube but what's interesting is
in this info panel
it has told me the exact python command
to replicate the thing i just did in the
ui and this is like this is game changer
because now
okay in a different panel i can open a
text editor
this will be say a new text file this is
by default like running python so i can
import
the blender python package which is
already like kind of pre-installed in it
and i can say like take this bit of code
that i've got from this panel
paste it in here and let me delete that
cube again
except this time instead of creating the
cube in the ui
i'll go to text run script
and it's recreated the cube now that's
pretty cool so i can programmatically
create stuff and not only that i can
sort of
easily discover the code to create so
i've i've done some pretty
like intense scripting with this without
even checking docs so i just
use the ui and do it and you can see
here like the the code here is pretty
pythonic like it's got it's pretty
explicit in terms of
what you can do with it so let me create
a couple more cubes
uh let me change the location of them so
put that one a bit higher in space put
that one a bit higher
and that one a bit higher uh i'll delete
this cube i don't need to delete but
i'll do it anyway
text one script look at that three cubes
all generated in space
and that's how easy it is to kind of
develop your python scripts
uh if you're already familiar with ui if
you're not it is a super intimidating ui
so i recommend doing like even some like
beginner course just to get familiar
with it
but uh yeah they it follows the ui
follows like good patterns so once you
learn
the sort of the basics they kind of
apply to it and it's nice consistent ui
so
it's a discoverable once you get the the
initial layout
uh understood uh so yeah that's that's
the python interface and that's how easy
it is to script
let me show you what i've been doing
with this uh
so as many of you maybe are aware of
if you're working with data science uh
you've probably heard of the iris data
set
raise your hand if you've heard of the
iris data set and hopefully i'm making a
gamble that more people have heard of it
yeah okay
a lot more people have heard of the iris
data set than i've heard of blender okay
that's awesome so you've probably
heard of it probably worked with it i've
also heard of it and worked with it
and i have created a notebook here to
create a basic sort of decision tree
model
with the iris data set so i do the first
thing here as everyone's used to doing
import ios data set from cycle learn uh
put it into x and y
and put it into pandas just to see it so
if you're not familiar with the iris
data set
what it is it's a data set of 150
flowers
it's tabular data it's got four columns
each column
has data about the length of the petal
width of the petal length of the sepal
with the sequel
and it's a classification problem where
it classifies
based on this data whether or not flower
is in
one of three different classes of flower
setoza virginica
and something else
and so yeah triple triple classification
kind of thing here is a visualization of
uh two of the columns of data so the
sequel width and the simple length i
think and the color represents the
classification
so uh if you've worked with you you've
probably trained models and you've
probably seen that yeah it's very easy
to classify
the iris data set at least the setoza
this is the satoshi's sitting right here
in the blue
it's a very it's one of the classif
classes is very easy to find the other
two have a bit of overlap
so that's the iris data set i trained a
decision tree model
to classify it still not that
interesting
uh but i also the um the actual
decision tree if you haven't done this
this is cool i've got the code for this
on my github for like quickly rendering
decision trees so i limited the
the depth of the decision tree did make
a nice simple decision tree
and i rendered it out so i've got a nice
simple decision tree that classifies
96 of the data excellent
that's what am i going to do with this
well uh
you saw that i it's pretty easy to write
pricing code to generate
cubes now this in this jupyter notebook
is all python code i can just copy this
over
in here although i'm not just going to
copy it over i have
prepared something uh what i created
in the past is file open
recent iris don't save
i've created this well what is this this
is let me make this bit bigger here
what i've created i've created the iris
data set in 3d
now the code is done here uh you can see
i'm i'm
it's python so i can import uh the iris
data set
as i would i'll go over how to install
cycler because the one thing that's a
bit tricky is
how to install new libraries in the
blender it's not the most intuitive but
it
i find a reasonably frictionless way of
doing it
so i've installed cycle learn and then
i've just kind of done what i normally
do import the data
uh and then i kind of went over the
rails where i
have procedurally iterated through the
data set and for each
uh data point i've generated a sphere
uh which is this this line i guess
and then for each sphere i've done some
other stuff like add rigid body
so if you're familiar with like working
with physics engines this is how you
make things like reactive physics
so yeah so i've created spheres with
rigid bodies
and i've actually assigned features of
the iris data set
to be features of this sphere so for
example the width of the sphere is the
width of the pedal
and then the bounciness of the sphere
is represents the length of the pedal so
those two features that i
that i used in my final decision tree
model those are the only two features in
theory i need to classify
this problem well so those are the only
two features in theory
i need to kind of simulate physically
and then uh
so just so what what i've done yeah i've
generated these marbles
so this if it's gonna load
it takes a while i've got a bit of a
slow computer here here we go so this is
the iris data set if it were marbles
uh we have you can see these these small
red ones these are very easy to classify
these are
the satosa flowers so i've also made the
color what the classification is so we
can see
how well the system works and i've even
went through the effort of making these
little bins with the names on them
and then i can run this uh so this is
unfortunately gonna take it's quite slow
i've got a six-year-old computer
and so when i want this to render like
well um
it's it's very time consuming but you'll
see hopefully
so the red ones that's the satoshi
flowers they're very easy to classify
those go straight in the bin
and then the bounciness being that other
feature
gets kind of judged this is this is
taking too long so what
what i also then did is i was like okay
this is this is rendering i've got an
old computer i don't want to
render on my computer and this is just
rendering like the non-fancy looking
version
uh if i actually want to render it
photorealistic you can see this takes
ages that's just to do one frame i
actually calculated how long this whole
animation would take to render it would
take approximately eight days of my
six-year-old computer
rendering which is pretty much like a
death sentence for a computer
so i didn't want to do that but i still
got it rendered and
how did i do that well i use this so
here's a version of it
that you saw it took quite a while to
render one frame now
it's quite a bit quicker and i can play
this and it goes a bit quicker but it's
okay that's rendering it every time
going a bit quicker um this is a quick
quick example i'm actually
using a vm for this so i'm running this
on my mac but it's actually a windows vm
and i recommend like if you're doing any
kind of rendering with this check out
the google cloud vm so i'm actually
using one of these vms
that has a uh nvidia graphics card in it
and you get free credits so you can use
these for
quite a while without having to pay
anything and i'm using a bit of software
called parsec
that gives you super low latency remote
desktop so low enough latency that you
can actually like play games on it
but that's that's that's not the point
so there's there's the marbles and
here's the actual final video
so i'll let this kind of play through
and it's like a meditative thing
and then what i also did is yesterday i
had an idea for another cool thing i
could do in blender
and after this is done i'll kind of go
to that idea but for now we can just
like
watch the marbles go i think if you
saw in the original notebook there's a
bit of overlap in one of the classic
classifications so
between the virginica and the versi
color
they overlap a bit and that's kind of
represented here not by design it's just
like if you
if you try to separate the marbles based
on bounciness they naturally overlap so
it's kind of doing a perfect perfect
visualization of a decision tree and how
it's
sort of independently looking at each
feature one after the other
and you can see there you have the
satosa flowers the red ones very easily
classified
and then the kind of bouncier ones
go so yeah so this
so this would have taken eight days on
my laptop but in the vm
it took eight hours so it's still a
crazy amount and now i can now see like
when you hear stories about how disney
takes like
like like a full two days to render one
frame i can kind of see why like
rendering this with realistic lighting
and stuff takes takes a long time
so that's that's an example of the iris
data which i did a while ago but an
example of something i did more recently
uh in fact i did yesterday uh is based
off of
oh actually first i'll quickly show um
here so this is if you want to install
uh other libraries in blender uh i've
got it on my github here so if you go to
iris dataset i've got a link at the end
of my talk so you can find this but the
the most handy bit is this so blender
comes with python pre-installed in it
with a version of pip and it's its own
version of python that's isolated in its
file system
so all you have to do is kind of uh find
the directory of that which is usually
this on a mac
so cd to the location of the blender app
go down the files until you find the
version of python
find the the sort of binary of it and
then just pip install using that binary
and that's it so you don't need to i i
stack overflowed it a bit
and people were saying how you need like
to install anacondas and stuff in your
own
uh virtual environments like now you
don't need that you just just find the
find its version of python and just
call that and call pip on that and that
should just work so
there is how you install your own custom
libraries and you can sell any library
because
it's just python now uh something i did
yesterday
i was based on this old project that i
did so this visualization of a neural
network
i was like this is perfect because i had
this sort of built physically but
now that i've kind of sort of gotten
used to this uh this virtual way of
building physical things i can maybe
remake this
and so that's exactly what i did so i i
wanted to replicate this using
uh sort of visualizing real-time
learning in a neural network just for
fun
and so i'll go back to this and i'll
show you what i made so here is
uh do open recent here it is
don't save here's what i created
so it's been rudimentary i haven't
polished it up like i did with the other
one
uh and the other one with the marbles i
the thing that was procedurally or
programmatically generated were just the
marbles and then i took a lot of time
building the actual kind of marble
machine but the
the marbles were all uh programmatically
generated uh for this
uh here is the code this one's a
bit cleaner so what i've got here i'm
generating
with code cubes and these are cubes that
glow
and the cubes the number of cubes
represents the number of
nodes in a neural network so i'm using
the
multi-layer perceptron classifier from
scikit-learn
because that's the exact same one i used
in my physical one um
training classifier 10 times 10 times 10
nodes in each layer or 10 in the first
three layers of 10 nodes in each layer
and they're kind of represented here
each connection is represented not each
node
and because uh the first layer has 10
nodes and the second layer has 10 nodes
that means there's 100 connections
because each
node connects to every other node so
that's why you have a 10 by 10 grid
in this kind of middle of the the thing
and yes so i've
each connection so each coefficient is
represented as a cube
and then i'm setting like a learning
rate
a reasonable learning rate of 0.01
i'm fitting it but then what i'm doing
is for each sort of cycle of learning
i am finding each uh
coefficient and finding its equivalent
cube and changing its sort of brightness
to its coefficient so yeah each it's
going to light up
based on each coefficient and if i play
this through it
they kind of shift subtly
and it's not that exciting
but it's kind of showing when like the
learning plateaus because everything
kind of stops moving but
it's a bit quicker if i just like move
it up and down so like okay
that's pretty cool but not that
interesting let's see like what happens
if i lower the learning rate
and then i rerun this so that's going to
sort of reassign
the uh the animations of when they're
going to light up
okay let's see this now okay that's even
more boring
so now it's moving even slightly
and not very interesting but let's say
what happens if we increase the learning
rate to something that's
considered unreasonable uh if you're
familiar with like the exploding
gradients problem
this might uh this might be a bit more
exciting so
i'll rerun this
all right it's running it's running oh
look at this we've got ourselves a
little supernova here
oh look at that
so you can see there very clearly that
uh all of our coefficients are kind of
out of whack
uh this is classic exploding gradients
where everything kind of bounces and
bunches and everything goes crazy and it
doesn't learn
and in fact when i run this code in a
collab i don't have an output of the
score here
because we don't really get like a um a
console log from this
which is unfortunate i think there is a
way of displaying it but i haven't
investigated how to do how to
show that but you can clearly see that
this is not a healthy looking neural
network
and it's kind of showing that in a what
i think a beautifully spectacular way
uh so yeah this is i think it would be
very cool if there was like
matplotlib 3d render
and then you get something that looks
like this you're like whoa it's
oh the neural network's literally
exploded
uh yeah you can this is done with cycle
and virtually any python thing
anything that's python can be used to
make these kind of cool renders and in
fact
uh if anyone is familiar with the reddit
thread called
data is beautiful uh quite often like
here's an example of one that i saw
recently
i'm almost 99 sure this was made with
blender
uh because it's because one it looks
really really nice and blender can make
these very nice
visually realistic looking things and i
can imagine this would actually be quite
straightforward to make a blender if
you've got like the um
the latin longitudes of each data point
i think this is showing the
population as like bar graphs but on an
actual map
so this kind of thing if you're
wondering like how these kind of really
pretty things are made
i'm 100 sure it's probably made with
blender
and there's loads of examples on like
data is beautiful you see these really
cool renders and this is the exact kind
of tool that's used to make them
um yeah that's pretty much it like
to end here is the link to the the
github
where it's got the code literally all of
the code to sort of make your
that shows my uh marble machine so the
actual all the scenes and assets
you can just open that and see it and
then also the instructions for how to
install custom libraries
uh in blender which i think are like i
think the easiest way of doing it
compared to other things i've seen
online
and then yeah i'm currently working with
uh
more sort of experimental things like
how to do machine learning in vr
so i've got myself one of these oculus
things and these are really cool because
because it's just running android i can
run things like tensorflow lite on it
very easily
so if you're interested in projects like
this or any other kind of 3d projects
within the lockdown period feel free to
follow me at zacakiel
but yeah that's it uh thank you all for
listening and i welcome
any questions
okay so let's do that again so i will go
first with my question and you ask your
questions on the qa
and then we we we go from there so
i guess the obvious question that we
have
is have you thought about 3d printing
the marbles and seeing that in the real
physical world
oh i have but um
uh i don't know how to replicate the
bounciness
in the 3d model uh but it did cross my
mind that
i could take whatever i have in this and
kind of 3d printed actually
that would be cool i haven't i did
consider it but then for the iris
dataset it's not that good because again
i need to somehow render
3d print bounciness i guess that could
be the density of it
but yeah no i i kind of consider it but
i think for the rsd it's a bit tricky
because yeah like i said i'm using
bounciness as one but
for something else when building
something else i'm definitely going to
consider it because yeah i've got
my own 3d printer there so i might do it
yeah
so yeah so we got a we got a question
uh on a qa so is uh did you ever find a
way to script the blender python process
i think the embedded interpreter is a
bit of a bottleneck preventing news
scripting from the rooting uh database
or data visualization tasks
um i don't fully understand the question
is it talking about
is it asking about like do you have to
write scripts all inside the blender
scripting environment
is that the question um
i'm sorry i can't see where's the key
let me see that uh
qa yeah so mike do you want to
to clarify the question
yeah the embedded controller uh is a
python interpreter and there is no api
um the embedded controller is a python
interpreter
oh so it's so because yeah so in in the
examples i've shown
i've written the python inside blender
and it's running its own kind of
it's within itself i mean do you need to
run blender oh do i need to run blend ui
at the moment yes i did quickly try to
investigate to see if i could sort of
code
to blender from like vs code today
um but unfortunately i can find a way it
seems like
like i even tried to find see if i could
find the actual like script file because
i figured oh if i can just
take the script file and bring it into
an id or something
uh that would be easier but it seems
like the blender file itself is all
one sort of compiled thing so i can't
even get to the script file as
it's by itself so the moment i haven't
it seems like yeah i do agree it's a
bottleneck but i did
like the cleanest way i found is that
you can make a separate window
though so it's uh at least at least you
don't have to code in like a small one
you can make it like full screen and
stuff
but yeah i do i do completely emphasize
like yeah
it's a bit tricky because i can't like
debug this that well or like or
log out stuff to the console so yeah at
the moment i haven't but
i'm sure someone else is probably fine
like there's so much open source stuff
going on around this so i'm sure someone
else has
found a way
yeah yeah okay so yeah that's that
so i guess
do you have any other questions on the
chat or on the qa
no no apparently not perfect
so do you do you have any other uh final
comments or something you want to
to mention um
no just like try blender it's really
cool
like example of like what great open
source software can do like it's
especially like the story behind it um i
think
they're based out of um amsterdam the
people who build it and yeah they're
just
really good open source software like
they uh there is initially i think the
the sort of 3d animation landscape used
to be just like these very very
expensive
sort of enterprise grade tools and now
blenders
sort of uh bumping shoulders with them
where people are
not using blender for real like
cinematography and stuff like that so
it's a great example of uh what open
source software can be so i think yeah
if you haven't tried it please please do
try if not
kind of at least look at some of the
documentaries about the people building
it because it's a really
cool uh bit of software yeah so i got
one more question in this meantime is
there any particular blender tutorial
you recommend
ah yeah so there's loads on on youtube
there's people like like blender guru
that show like these very quick
distilled um uh
sort of tutorials like this there's this
guy things called ian hilbert
who does like two-minute kind of
comedy-based tutorials of like quirky
things you can do but i think those
tutorials are more designed for
if you're already familiar with the ui
and stuff they kind of assume that you
know like your way around
uh if you don't then there's this one
which is this is the one i did
and it's it was phenomenal like it
really assumed absolutely zero knowledge
and it's teaching uh like the latest ui
because like it's
blender is such a mature tool and it's
it's been through so many different ui
iterations but this this is a
example of a program that is actually
teaching like with the modern
version of it and it taught really well
it's pretty
long and extensive like if you've got
some spare time over lockdown
uh then i'd recommend it uh but yeah
this is this is one i used and it
worked really well for me so i recommend
this one
cool well uh
we got no no other questions so
i'd like to thank you very much uh
uh also vidi for taking the time to
present here to us tonight uh thank you
very much for your talks
if you want to send your slides or any
links
uh you can send them on the meetup
page or you can send them to us
on our email and then we will publish
them
there
thank you very much for your
presentation i'll try to upload the
video
as soon as possible and let you know
thank you for all who join tonight
thanks for coming and we see you in
next month yeah have a
good recipe your evening
thank you cool thank you thanks a lot